翻訳: Kiyokazu Konishi
校正: Masaki Yanagishita
みなさんこんにちは
（こんにちは）
私 ４年前に 脳出血をしました
この脳出血というのは
前兆というものが ２週間前からありました
それ どういった前兆かというと
２週間前から 偏頭痛があったんですね
この偏頭痛というのは
そのまま左側なんですけれども
ずっと痛みがあって
ただ 当時の私は 29歳でした
29の私は 偏頭痛というのは
まあ きっとそのうち治るだろう
そういう気持ちの中で
まあ 無視をしました
その結果 私は２週間後に
脳出血を起こしました
これは 私が その出血をした時に
メモを取ったものなんですが
これ 私 その出血をした時に
頭の中から 自分の中から
色々なものが 消えて行く感じというのを
すごく感じました
で 慌てて 妻にお願いをして
メモ帳をくれと
メモ帳を取って欲しいと
お願いして
メモ帳を取ってもらって
メモを取り始めました
で 書き始めから
違和感を感じていたのですが
その数分後には 私は もう
自分が言葉を書けなくなってしまって
うまく話すことも 出来なくなってしまいました
こういった形で 私は自分の中から色々な
能力というのを失って行ったんですが
何も 失ってしまったのは
その能力とかそう いったものだけではなくて
大切な人との関係であったりとか
自分が大切だと思っていた人との
関係だったりとか
色々なものが 脳出血を起こしたことで
ガラッと 変わって行きました
そして 私は 120日間の入院と
２度の手術
それに 3,000時間を超えたリハビリ
そういったものの中から 学んだことを
今日みなさんにお話ししたいと 思っています
特に困ったことは
字が書けなくなったこと
みなさん想像出来ますか
この ひらがなが書けないとか
字が書けないことって 想像できますか
全く出てこない
それに 同時に 読めなくなりました
ですから 私にとって
その看板に書いてある文字っていうのは
絵と同じものなんですね
なので 当然ながら 相手が話していることも
頭の中で 言葉で変換することが出来ないので
理解をするまでに ものすごい時間がかかる
という状態になってしまいました
で その中で
道も 看板も読めないですし
自分がどこにいるかも
本当に 分からなくなってしまうので
まあ 道に迷ってしまうんですね
それに 視野の半分を失いました
これは こういう風に 手を広げて頂いて
見て頂くと 良く分かるんですが
皆さん こう手を広げると
大体 左手と右手というのが
こう 見えていると 思うんですね
で これが視野を失うとどうなるかというと
ここと 私の場合は 右側なんですが
ここが真っ暗になってしまうんです
ですから 人がこう歩いてくると
ここから急に人が登場する
あるいは人と話していて
３人で話していたりいると
こちらの人の表情が分からなければ
どういったことを どういう気持ちで
話しているのかっていうのも
見て想像することは出来ないので
こう常に顔を向けて
その人が見てるかな
どうしているかなっていう形で 話をするので
もう不安で
ちゃんと 話が伝わっているのかなとか
そういった状態になりました
で その中で 私が 特に困ってしまったことが
外出が出来ないことです
これは 自分が何処にいるかも
分からなくなってしまうので
家族は 私に その連絡先を書いた紙を
渡してくれるんですね
妻の連絡先だったりとか
親の連絡先が書いてあるものを
握りしめて出て行くんですけれども
自分の持って行った紙を
何処にしまってしまったんだとか
そういったことも
忘れてしまうので
一人で外出することも
出来なくなりました
また バス停で その中でも頑張ろうと思って
自分一人で 何とかバスに乗ろうと思って
バスに乗りました
バスに乗ろうとしました
ただ その乗ろうとしているバスが
この字が本当に合っている所に
行くかどうかが 分からないので
私 一緒に並んでいた人に
このバスは どこどこに行きますかって
いう風に尋ねたんですね
そうすると 恐らく
私のやり取りっていうものが
きっと ちょっと
違和感を感じるものだったと思います
私 その人から 「あっ お前 障害者か」 と
「お前みたいな障害者がいるから―
日本って良くならないんだよね」
って言われました
また 仕事もうまくすることが
出来なくなってしまって
まあ 自分自身が
物事の計画を立てるということが
本当に苦手になってしまって
次に何をしなければいけないのかってのが
本当に分からなく なったんですね
で ただ一生懸命やろうとしたんですが
出来ない
その中で 「お前は本当に
自分のことしか考えてないな」
という風に言われるようになりました
倒れる数時間前まで
部下を持って 一つの部門を任されて
現場の一線で働いていた私は
ものすごい 悔しい気持ちになりましたし
悲しい気持ちになりました
でも 一番辛かったのは
私に対して いつも
「チームワークが大事だよ」 という風に
教えてくれていた人がいたんですが
私 うまく話すことができなくなって
相手の言っていることを理解するのに
すごく時間が かかってしまった私は
私は その人から無視されるようになりました
で やっぱりその自己表現というものが
出来なくなったことで
色々な思いをして
その中で感じたことがあったんです
それは 自己表現って
何なのかなって 思ったんですね
うまく自分の言いたいことを
伝えられなければいけないのか と
でも私は 後天的に その出血をしたことで
そういったものが苦手になりましたが
でも 元々 自分の表現をすることというのが
そんなに得意でない方だったりとか
先天的に自己表現が
できない方っていうのも いると思うんですね
じゃあ そういう方にとって
自分をPRすることって
そんなに大切なことなのかなって
もっと歩み寄って
何を考えているのかなとか
きっとこの人はこういう風にして欲しいんじゃ
ないかなという風に
寄り添うことっていうので
コミュニケーションを取ることも出来るんでは
ないかなと いう風に思うようになりました
また 言葉というものは
見えるものではないんですが
ああ こんなに
人を傷つけることが出来るんだ
そういうことを 思うようになりました
そういうことが 続いて
自分の表現が出来なくなったことで
もう本当に 人生 止めたいな ということを
思うことが 続いていたんですが
その中でも いい事もありました
それは 私が入院をして
たくさんの方が お見舞いに来てくれて
その中には お客様であったりとか
パートナーさんだったりとか
あるいは 自分にとって
すごく大切な 可愛い後輩だったりとか
会社の同僚が 何度も
お見舞いに来てくれたんですね
その中で 私 初めは 顔も見られなかったです
自分がもう 何も出来なくなっている
ということを認めていたので
恥ずかしい気持ちだったりとか
悲しい気持ちだったりとか
そういったものが一杯で 辛かったんですが
でも同時に
あっ 自分がこんな状態になっても
お見舞いに来てくれる人がいるっていうのは
すごく嬉しいことだなと思いました
ある人は 一人で外出も出来なくなって
うまく話すことが出来なくなった私を―
近くの喫茶店まで連れて行ってくれて
私は こういう風に言われました
「あぁ 生きていて良かった」 って
私 もう自分の体も健康も
信用出来ない状態だったので
その中で 生きてるだけで良かった って
あぁ 生きてて良かったんだって
本当に心から思って
あぁ そうなんだと思いました
また 義理の母は
私が倒れてから ずっと一貫して
「あなたの病気は 薄皮を剥ぐように
良くなっているから」
そういう形で 私が良くなるということを
ずっと 信じてくれたんですね
また 私の妻は 私の120日間の入院の間―
ほとんど毎日 どんなに仕事が忙しくても
お見舞いに来てくれました
そういった人の気持ちに応えたいと
そういう気持ちの中で感じたことは
言葉って とか 態度って
こんなにも 自分を頑張らせて
くれるんだなってことを 思いました
同時に 人は 自分のためだけに
頑張ろうと思ったら
無理が 限界が
あるんだなと いうことも 分かりました
その中 私は
リハビリということを 続けることにしました
このリハビリというのは
例えば みなさん 風邪をひいた時に
きっとこう思うと 思うんです
風邪を引いて 薬を飲んで
しばらくしたら 治るよなっていう風に
思うと 思うんですけども
このリハビリっていうのは
どこまでやったら 治るかっていうのが
全く分からないものですし
人によって様々なものなので
特に 自分の体の状況っていうのは
あまりよろしくない状態なので
そのリハビリを
続けていくっていうこと自体が
そもそもすごく 大変なことなんですけども
ただ 私は そういった
温かい言葉だったりとか
温かい配慮をしてくれた人のために
もう一度 一緒に働きたいとか
何とか その人たちの気持ちに応えたいと
そういう気持ちで リハビリを続けました
特に 先ほど見て頂いた 視野の問題
「これは リハビリが無い」 と言われました
一度 見え無くなくなってしまった視野は
戻りません[という意味です]
ただ 私は もう一度 自分にとって
大切な人たちと 一緒に過ごすために
どうしても諦めることが 出来なかったんです
そんな中 ある大学病院は
私の リハビリに対する想いだったりとか
治療の可能性っていうのを 信じてくれました
この黒くなっている所というのが
実際に 視野欠損 という
要は欠損してしまった
見えなくなってしまった
視野の部分と思うんです
リハビリを始める前は
2012年の頃よりも もう少し
真っ黒な状態が多かったんですけれども
これがリハビリを始めたことで
すごく回復を感じました
本当に薄皮を剥ぐようにですが
私の視野は 回復して行きました
また 読むこと 聞くこと 話すこと
こういった障害に対しては
専任の言語聴覚士の先生
言語聴覚士の方というのを
ご存知でしょうか
私は 倒れて初めて知ったんですけれども
この言語聴覚士の先生方が
今の私に合ったもの
というものを常に探してくれました
私 倒れた時は 29歳の時に
ひらがな帳からスタートしました
もう一度 アイウエオを順に言う
練習からスタートしました
で 本当に悲しいし 屈辱的な気持ちで
いっぱいだったんですけれども
でも この言語聴覚士の先生が
いつも私に合ったリハビリを探してくれて
そういうことに応えたいという気持ちで
私は リハビリを ずっと続けて来ました
その結果
私は 日本語だけではなくて
私の元々の専門分野である
ITの関係の専門分野
具体的には
プログラム言語 というものがあります
パソコンのプログラムを組む言語です
それを 再度ですね 日本語を獲得しながら
もう一度 私
専門学校に入りました
その専門学校に 31才の時に入学をして
また 改めて勉強をしました
結果的に 私は そういった言語だったり
視野というのを また再度獲得する中で
自分自身の プライドであったりとか
尊厳というものを 取り戻して行きました
お陰様で 私は また
自分の大切な人たちと一緒に
仕事をすることが出来るようになりました
また 一時は 諦めていた
子どもにも 出会うことが出来て
私 こう思うんです
私が 今こうやって
この場に立っているのは
本当に そう言った温かい言葉であったり
態度をとってくれた人がいたから
そのおかげで 今の自分はここにいると
心から思います
あなたは 今日
あなたにとって大切な人と お話をしましたか
きっと あなたの態度や言葉っていうので
誰かが前向きになること
誰かが無理だと思ってたことに
チャレンジし続けることができる
と私は思っています
そして
色々な言葉の暴力や態度
そう言ったものに対しても
それに対して
責める気持ちを持つのではなくて
私は 許す気持ちが
大事であるということを知りました
自分の心が辛くなること
責め続けるというのは
相手を責め続けること というのは
相手を責め続けるということで
自分の心がすごく辛くなる
ということも良く分かりました
それから もしみなさんも
もしそう言った思いがあったとしても
どこかで許して
そして 自分にとって大切な人に
温かい言葉や 温かい態度を
取って欲しいなと思います
その中でまた 自分が続けていること
今すぐには答えが出ないことって
たくさんあると思うんです
私も 実際 その視野の回復っていうのを
しっかり感じるまでには
多くの年数を必要としました
また言語を回復するのにも
すごく時間がかかりました
でも 無理だなと思っていることがあっても
諦めずに続けて
可能性があるという風に
信じてみませんか
ありがとうございました
（拍手）